the grand jury voted to return an
indictment
against detective hankinson for three
counts
of wanton endangerment for wantonly
placing
the three individuals in apartment three
in danger
of serious physical injury or death a
grand jury indicted
louisville police detective brett
hankinson in connection with the death
of brianna taylor on wednesday
charging him with three counts of wanton
endangerment
the charge one endangerment in the first
degree is a class
d felony and if found guilty the accused
can serve up to five years
for each count kentucky attorney general
daniel cameron announced the news during
a press conference it's important to
note that he is presumed innocent
until proven guilty the two other
officers involved in the case
jonathan mattingly and miles cosgrove
were not
charged and none of the officers were
charged for their role in taylor's
death according to kentucky law the use
of force by mattingly
and cosgrove was justified to protect
themselves
taylor a 26-year-old emt was fatally
shot by police in her apartment on march
13 after officers entered her apartment
while she and her boyfriend kenneth
walker were sleeping
her death sparked protests worldwide
with activists athletes politicians and
celebrities calling for the officers
involved to be charged criminally
i know that not everyone will be
satisfied with the charges we've
reported today
my team set out to investigate the
circumstances surrounding
miss taylor's death we did it with a
singular
goal in mind pursuing the truth
louisville police turned over the
investigation into the shooting to
kentucky attorney general daniel
cameron's office in may
there will be celebrities influencers
and activists who having never lived in
kentucky
would try to tell us how to feel
suggesting they
understand the facts of this case that
they know our community
and the commonwealth better than we do
but they don't let's not give in to
their attempts to influence
our thinking or capture our emotions
following wednesday's announcement some
of hollywood's biggest stars were quick
to chime in
carrie washington tweeting quote daniel
cameron is on donald trump's
short list as replacement of rbg on the
supreme court
the same man who decided to not charge
the officers responsible for killing
briana taylor
vote mandy moore wrote that she doesn't
have the words adding
brianna taylor and her family deserve
justice
meghan mccain asked that her fans pray
for taylor's family
and send them strength while jojo sent
her love to taylor's family
taylor's sister junaya shared this pic
on instagram
alongside the caption sister i am so
sorry
she also shared this message in her
insta story
quote sister you was failed by a system
you worked hard for
and i am so sorry i love you so so
so so so much
you